SHOOTING PORNOGRAPHY BRINGS ME
UNIMAGINABLE JOY.
WHEN I COMPLETED AN HONEST DAY'S
WORK.
IT IS MY LOVE AND MY HAPPINESS
AND MY HOME.
I CAN SAY I NEVER FELT MORE
EMPOWERED OR HAPPY DOING
ANYTHING ELSE IN A WORLD WHERE
WOMEN ARE WRONGED OF CHOICE, IT
IS WONDERFUL AND IT IS HOW THE
WORLD SHOULD BE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE SHOW WILL
RIP THAT TO SHREDS.
WE WANTED TO TALK TO A WOMAN WHO
SAID GOOD FOR HER.
MICHELLE, CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST
JOINS ME NOW WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT PERSPECTIVE.
YOU CALLED MY PRODUCER BRAVE,
BRILLIANT AND A BAD BLEEP.
WHY?
>> I DID.
I THINK WHAT IS SO IMPORTANT,
BROOKE, IS THAT IN OUR SOCIETY
RIGHT NOW THERE IS SO MUCH
SHAMING GOING ON AND SO MUCH
FEAR AROUND ANY WOMAN OWNING HER
SEXUALITY.
I AM A HAPPY EXPERT AND I TRY TO
KEEP MARRIAGES TOGETHER.
I TRY TO GET PEOPLE TO HAVE MORE
SEX.
I THINK THAT IN THE EROTIC
INDUSTRY, THERE A LOT OF WOMEN
THAT I MET AND MEN WHO DO THAT
HAS A JOB AND ARE NOT ON DRUGS.
THEY ARE VERY CONFIDENT AND
CAPABLE AND COULD DO A LOT OF
OTHER WORK.
BUT THEY CHOOSE TO DO THIS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE NOTE.
IT IS NOT AS BAD AS WHAT PEOPLE
ARE PUTTING OUT.
>> I'M ALWAYS AWARE OF THE
THOUGHT BUBBLES OF VIEWERS
WATCHING A SEGMENT AND I CAN
HEAR THEM RAPID FIRE LIKE IF YOU
WERE TO WATCH PORN AND THINGS
DONE TO WOMEN.
HOW IS THAT EMPOWERING.
I READ THIS TWICE.
IN PARTS, I'M WITH HER UNTIL I
GOT TO THE PARENT PART.
UNTIL SHE SAID HERE I AM, AN
EMPOWERED WOMAN AND I LIED TO MY
PARENTS AND TOLD THEM I HAD
EXTRA EXAMS AND I SHOOT
PORNOGRAPHY.
I AM WONDERING IF I HAD HER IN
FRONT OF ME HOW EMPOWERED SHE IS
WHEN SHE IS LYING TO HER PARENTS
AND REMAINS ANONYMOUS.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S ALSO ABOUT HER
BEING IN FEAR OF BEING VIEWED
EXACTLY THE WAY SHE HAS BEEN BY
ALL THE SHAMING THAT HAS BEEN
GOING ON.
I THINK SHE SAID A LOT OF SMART
THINGS IN HER ARTICLE.
>> SHE'S A GREAT WRITER.
I GIVE HER THAT.
>> YEAH, AND I THINK THAT AGAIN,
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
FEMALE SEXUALITY.
I TALK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME.
WE GET COMMENTS ABOUT RIHANNA
SHOULDN'T DO THIS AND BRITNEY
SPEARS AND MADONNA KISSING AND
ALL THAT SORT OF STUFF.